foreign
[Music]
I guarantee you that at some point
everything's going to go south on you
ready
you're gonna say this is it
this is how I end
up command right Mark is dead
now you can either accept that
or you can get to work this will come as
quite a shock to my crewmates
head to NASA end of the entire world but
I'm still alive
surprise
here's the rub it's gonna be four years
for another mission to reach me
and I'm in a hat design the last 31 days
so I gotta make water and grow food on a
planet where nothing grows
but if I can figure out a way to make
contact with NASA none of this matters
anyway I've got an incoming message
still alive
in your face Neil Armstrong
[Music]
okay so let's do the math I have enough
food to last for 50 days he's going to
starve to death long before we can help
so I'm gonna have to science the [__]
out of this he's 50 million miles away
from home he's totally alone what the
hell is he thinking right now I am the
greatest botanist on this planet
I know how to save Mark Watney but we
need the Hermes crew we either have a
high chance of killing one or a little
chance of coming six I'm not risking
their lives it's bigger than one person
yeah so
NASA rejected the mission so if we do
this we're talking Mutiny if anything
goes wrong
we die do you realize how that's how
crazy this is
we have no other option
no matter what happens
tell the world
to my family
[Music]
never stop fighting to make it home
foreign
[Music]
give it something socially responsible
can't we just let it go
this thing needs to run out of that game
Let's mask up
like the rest of it
[Music]
there's worlds of treasure
there's been telling us to leave for a
while now
your daughter's generation will be the
last to survive on Earth
you're the best pilot we ever had
get out there and save the world
everybody really say goodbye to our
solar system
to our galaxy
here we go
right here
I get down fast don't we actually we
want to get there in one piece
[Music]
we have a mission our mission does not
work if the people on Earth are dead by
the time we pull it off
foreign
further than any human in history well
not far enough
[Music]
let's make a cow
no waves
yes you are yes you are
you might have to decide between senior
children again
and the future of the human race
we'll find a way that we always have
300 this morning tdrs picked up an
automated navigation Beacon broadcasting
a two-minute intervals in Neptune orbit
this is incredible it's the Event
Horizon she come back
and then Horizon was a combination of a
secret government project to create a
spacecraft capable of faster than light
flight ship doesn't really go faster
than light what it does is it creates a
dimensional Gateway that allows it to
jump instantaneously from one point of
the universe to another light years away
where she'd been for the last seven
years Doctor
that's what we're here to find out
after seven years in deep space 18
people on board this ship when it
disappeared I want them all accounted
for
came back abandoned negative
this place is a tune
but it didn't come back alone
[Music]
the boundaries of our universe
that was where it's been
I wanted to brought back with it
the ship is reacting to us and the
reactions are getting stronger
what are you telling me that this ship
is alive
oh my God
it knows my secrets
I can't believe
[Music]
Dave do you mind if I ask you a personal
question
no not at all
[Music]
I've wondered whether you might be
having some second thoughts about the
mission
[Music]
how do you mean
rumors about something being dug up on
the moon
I never gave these stories much credence
particularly in view of some of the
other things that have happened
I find them difficult to put out of my
mind
open the pod bay doors please Hal
open the pod bay doors hell
[Music]
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that
what are you talking about hell
this conversation can serve no purpose
anymore
goodbye
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
she was your hero
she'd give his life for the pursuit of
knowledge
[Music]
it's crazy out there there's fires
everywhere and plane crashes they're
calling it The Search
major we have some highly classified
information what can you tell us about
the Lima project
its objective was to search for advanced
extraterrestrial life
the ship disappeared approximately 16
years into the mission and the commander
was
my father sir
this might come as quite a shock to you
your father was experimenting with a
highly classified material that could
threaten our entire solar system all
light would be destroyed we're counting
on you to find out what's happening out
there
I worry about you I love you
please begin your psychological
evaluation
as best you can please describe your
current mental and emotional state I'm
feeling good ready to do my job to the
best of my abilities
I remain fully committed to the lawful
completion of the mission
if necessary I will destroy the project
in its entirety
the earthquakes hopes in him
and now now it's fake
it's not me
[Music]
we have a job to do
are you ready
I'm ready
[Music]
explore has been hit Explorer
listen to my voice
[Music]
I told you nothing I see
I see no you have a vehicle by SS no you
need to focus
on Earth
so where's home I just done
Lake Zurich Illinois
is there somebody down there looking up
thinking about you
I had a daughter
A little girl with brown hair
tell her that I'm not quitting
laughs
[Music]
Sam Bell reporting to Central everything
running smoothly over and out rock and
roll God Bless America
good morning Sam do you want me to cut
your hair then
lunar Industries Remains the number one
provider of clean energy worldwide due
to the hard work of people like you know
three years is a long haul you know I
know you're really lonely up there but
I'm proud of you
[Music]
let's go Sam
looks like we got a live one I'm gonna
go out okay Sam
surround working perimeter
I'm outside
who is he you tell me who that is
perhaps you're imagining things
what's going on
where did he come from why does he look
like me
up here too long man you've lost your
marbles
hey what's up
[Music]
I'm gonna go home I know
I come from Earth a planet of Outlaws
my name is Peter Quill
there's one other name you might know me
by Star-Lord
who a Star-Lord man legendary Outlook
guys
forget it
[Applause]
[Music]
so here we are
a Thief two thugs
an assassin
Animaniac
but we're not gonna stand by his evil
wipes out of the Galaxy
I guess we're stuck together partners
are you telling me the fate of 12
billion people
is in the hands of these criminals oh
yeah
[Music]
I look around you know what I see losers
but mine's giving us a chance
to do what something good
something bad a bit of both oh what the
hell I don't got that long a lifespan
anyway
ah
I'm trying to feel
[Music]
in love with me
I'm rude ain't no thing like me except
me they call themselves The Guardians of
the Galaxy
this might not be the best idea
I'm trying to feel it
she's smart
[Music]
where is calm
trash
refuse that didn't fit into the system
until someone had the right idea
they're recycling us
to serve science
[Music]
the odds are not enough fever but when
my work is accomplished when Perfection
is achieved then what fly away
I know I look like a witch if you're
foxy and you know it
foreign
to some type of Glory I can't do this
flying around no more
you lied to us
you knew it
[Music]
the sensation moving backwards
even though we're moving forwards
getting further from what's getting here
[Applause]
[Music]
there's nothing to fear everything's
gonna be fine
you realize nothing is ever gonna go
inside us
break the laws of nature
now pay for it
[Music]
I couldn't believe it when the bartender
told me who you are
why are you talking to me man
your father was Captain of Starship for
12 minutes
he saved 800 lives
including yours
do better
enlist in Starfleet
you will experience fear
fear in the face of certain death
we received a distress call
I've been waiting for this day my whole
life
[Music]
foreign
first officer to replace
yeah we do
[Music]
you are capable of deciding your own
destiny the question is
which pathway you choose
[Music]
foreign
are you sure yeah
be an adventure
first man to walk on the moon
that'd be something
you've chosen a job so difficult
requiring so many technological
developments
we're gonna have to start from scratch
foreign only after we Master these tasks
do we consider trying to land on the
Moon
Neil if his flight is successful you'll
go down in history what kind of thoughts
do you have about that we're planning on
the flight being successful
damn that is a big mother it'll go up
like a half kiloton A-bomb if it blows
the vehicle's not safe you need to fail
down here so we don't fail up there this
isn't just another trip Neil you're not
just going to work do you think you're
coming back
there are risks but we have every
intention of coming back
somebody got a Swiss Army knife
nice too nice
here we go six
live four three
two
do you question whether the program's
worth the cost in money in and last
down here and you look up and you don't
think about it too much but space
exploration changes your perception
it allows us to see things that we
should have seen a long time ago we have
serious problems
we've got this under control you're a
bunch of boys you don't have anything
under control
thank you
[Music]
I will not let this Republic be split in
two my negotiations will not fail if
they do there aren't enough Jedi to
protect the Republic we're keepers of
the peace not soldiers
[Music]
you know I don't like it when you do
that sorry Master I forgot you don't
like flying well you've lost it if
you'll excuse me
don't do anything without first
Consulting either myself or the council
you don't need guidance Anakin I see you
are becoming the greatest of all Jedi
the boy has exceptional skills his
abilities have made him arrogant excuse
me I'm in charge of security here milady
[Music]
we must stop them before they're ready
your clones are very impressive they'll
do their job well
plus that's why I hate flying
not a crisis
must vote the chancellor emergency
Powers as my First Act I will create a
Grand Army of the Republic
to counter the increasing threats of the
separatists hasn't been a full-scale war
since the formation of the Republic
join me Obi-Wan and together we'll
destroy the Sith the dark side clouds
everything in grave danger you are
foreign
[Music]
700 years into the future
mankind will leave our planet leaving
Earth's cleaner in the hands of one
incredible machine
his name is Wally after all these years
he's developed one little glitch a
personality he's extremely curious
[Applause]
and just a little bit lonely
but all that is about to change
[Music]
thank you
Wally
[Music]
oh that's that robot
wow
10 seconds to self-destruct
you are now free to move around the
cabin
you look gorgeous
[Music]
in the far reaches of the Galaxy
a civilization is under siege we are all
that is left they've searched the
universe for a leader stay tuned for
scenes from next week's Galaxy Quest
never give up
Never Surrender you will save us
what they got never give up and never
surrender
we're struggling TV actors
[Applause]
[Music]
and they're about to put on a Command
Performance
the actors not astronauts you are
[Music]
that was a hell of a thing
now Laredo take us out
gonna move to the right would you sit
down you want to drive this thing
acting like Heroes
the whole thing was just a misunderstood
may not be enough
[Music]
they look like little children huh hi
little guy
DreamWorks Pictures presents Tim Allen
Sigourney Weaver Alan Rickman Galaxy
Quest you're just gonna have to kill it
[Music]
I'd like to know what you feel as far as
the responsibilities of representing
mankind on this trip
that's relatively difficult to answer or
it's a job that we collectively said
that was possible and we could do and
and of course the nation itself is
backing us so we just sincerely hope
that we measure up to that
foreign
program was designed to get two
Americans to the lunar surface and Back
Again Dura safely the enormity of this
event is something that only SP will be
able to judge
[Music]
Apollo 11 is very simply been given the
mission of carrying men to the moon
landing them there and bringing them
safely back
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]